a familiar sight
but the chants have been getting quieter
the placards are coming down
most health unions have accepted the
government's latest pay deal but the
nurses are holding out none of us want
to be the nurses on the picket line but
you know we've been driven to this
patients aren't dying because nurses are
striking nurses are striking because
patients are dying on non-strike days
and that's crucial you know we want to
be the best nurses we can we want to
provide great patient outcomes we want
to be able to hold the hands and do all
the jobs that we need to do but unless
the Staffing are there we aren't able to
do it
when RCN Members First went on strike in
December they were demanding a 19 pay
rise but as negotiations progressed
their leader Pat Cullen advised her
members to accept an offer of five
percent plus a one-off cash bonus
but they refused rejecting the offer
with a 54 majority
it put the RCN and another Union unite
at odds with 14 other health unions who
accepted the deal
RCN members will be balloted for strike
action again on the 23rd of May the RCN
Union is now considering another round
of strike action it's the leader Pat
Cullen initially urged nurses to accept
the government's pay deal
they refused so she changed Tac and as
the Union's Congress gets underway here
in Brighton she's reinstating her
initial demands of a double-digit pay
rise for nurses
ministers have been quick to seize on
the leaders indecision and they aren't
impressed it's a very curious story
indeed because Pat Gallup just recently
was encouraging her members to settle
for the pay rise that was put on the
table uh that would see 5000 pounds go
into the pockets of this year of our
hard-working nurses it's frankly rather
confusing now that having encouraged her
members to accept that deal she seems to
now be coming back and saying the
opposite confusing as it may be for the
government Pat Cullen is urging them to
avoid making the same mistakes she did
her message is clear
don't underestimate the nurses
Sky News
[Music]